[Musique]
bonjour à tous soyez les bienvenus sur
France 3 franchement t'es la chaîne des
élections municipales depuis le début de
la semaine et jusqu'à jeudi de la
semaine prochaine nous vous proposons
chaque soir à 18h un débat avec les
candidats des principales villes encore
en jeu en Franche-Comté avant ce fameux
deuxième tour du 28 juin ce soir deux
débats pour le prix d'un dans une
vingtaine de minutes je recevrai sur ce
plateau les trois candidats en lice pour
la mairie de Salins-les-Bains dans le
Jura mais d'abord Bavilliers dans le
Territoire de Belfort deux candidats
briques de la mairie de la 5ème ville la
plus peuplée du département
Eric coberley vous êtes le maire sortant
les républicains vous avez pris la ville
à la gauche en 2014 vous aviez alors
l'étiquette modem vous avez aujourd'hui
40 ans et vous êtes également
vice-président du département face à
vous Gérald lorida militant la France
insoumise vous menez pour ce scrutin une
liste divers gauche vous avez 63 ans et
vous êtes enseignant
aujourd'hui les bavier Roy les
baviroises ils veulent qu'on investisse
pour l'avenir de notre commune notamment
dans le domaine de l'éducation par
exemple mais aussi dans le domaine de la
santé particulièrement après la crise
que nous venons de vivre et donc nous
proposons aujourd'hui de construire une
école et de construire un cabinet
médical
ils veulent aussi que ces
investissements se fassent en respectant
leur cadre de vie en respectant
l'environnement et donc nous allons
associer les baviers rois comme nous
l'avons fait dans le premier mandat à
l'élaboration de ces projets
pour terminer il souhaite aussi que nous
soutenions l'emploi local parce que la
crise sanitaire c'est aussi une crise
économique et donc à travers ses
commandes publiques et bien nous allons
donner du travail à nos entreprises
géraldorida qui êtes-vous et pourquoi
êtes-vous candidat à la mairie de
Bavilliers
alors j'ai 63 ans je suis professeur des
écoles instit comme on dit j'ai commencé
une carrière comme ouvrier chez bulle
puis technicien et pendant toute cette
carrière j'ai été militant syndical plus
récemment j'ai participé à des campagnes
électorales au législatif par exemple et
il m'a semblé plus récemment qu'il était
important de s'investir au niveau local
parce que c'est à ton droit là à ce
niveau là qu'on peut agir vraiment avec
les citoyens
j'ai donc rejoint ce groupe baby et
c'est vous qui était un groupe qui
soutenait les
conseillé d'opposition il y a un peu
plus d'un an lors d'une lutte qui avait
été menée à bavier lors de la
disparition de la poste et puis ce
groupe a voulu proposer une alternative
autour de la solidarité l'écologie et
puis la démocratie participative et nous
avons pris quelques mois pour rédiger
ensemble une proposition de programme
pour bavier pour que la ville change
alors changer la ville on l'a entendu le
maire sortant un projet de nouvelle
école il a commencé par ce point là vous
à gauche vous avez des doutes sur la
nécessité d'investir dans ce nouveau
groupe scolaire est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer pourquoi alors ce qui est
sûr c'est que la maternelle a besoin
d'être un minima rénové elle est trop
bruyante elle n'est pas adaptée au
changement de température
elle fuit nous ce que vous nous voulons
faire avant tout c'est une étude un
diagnostic fait par un cabinet
d'expertise puis un chiffrage d'une
éventuelle rénovation on est a priori
pas fermé si on nous dit que ça n'est
pas faisable que ça va coûter une
fortune mais on veut avoir toutes les
cartes en main avant de se décider et on
le décidera avec la propagation puisque
notre
credo ce sera la démocratie
participative
Eric coberley pourquoi construire plutôt
que rénover l'école maternelle actuelle
a été construite dans les années 80 elle
a été mal conçue à l'époque elle est
construite sur un terrain instable donc
elle est aujourd'hui très endommagée et
c'est un gouffre thermique nous voulons
construire une école verte une école
éco-responsable et donc nous allons
construire un bâtiment à énergie
positive ce qui permettra de réduire la
fracture énergétique je prends l'exemple
de la commune de Châtenois-les-Forges
qui a construit une nouvelle école et
qui a diminué par 5 sa facture
énergétique
la crainte de Gérald lorida c'est que ça
coûte trop cher est-ce que Bavilliers a
les moyens de d'investir dans une
nouvelle école comme ça
en matière de financement dans le
premier dans le premier mandat nous
avons géré les finances publiques de la
commune avec beaucoup de rigueur nous
avons maîtrisé notamment les dépenses de
fonctionnement et notamment la masse
salariale nous allons financer nous en
trois points pour financer cette
nouvelle école d'abord nous avons
reconstitué une épargne nette d'à peu
près 800 000 euros
deuxièmement nous aurons des subventions
de l'état du département et de
l'agglomération qui tous les trois ont
créé des fonds spécifiques pour soutenir
l'économie et soutenir l'emploi local
après la crise que nous venons de vivre
et enfin nous allons pouvoir faire un
emprunt raisonnable puisque si nous
construisons une école pour 50-80 ou 100
ans il n'est pas illogique d'emprunter
sur 20 ans d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui
les taux d'intérêt sont extrêmement bas
est-ce que ce que vous venez d'entendre
vous rassure géralda pas tout à fait
pour plusieurs raisons parce que
beurrelet parle d'une école
écologique et je suis moi ça m'étonne de
devenir écologiste quelque part par
opportunisme au dernier moment en une
semaine comme il me disait quelqu'un
pour transformer un terrain une
agriculture ordinaire en agriculture bio
faut 3 ans Monsieur coverlay le fait en
deux semaines alors si il avance dans ce
sens je dis c'est bien on est inquiet
quand même sur cette grosse dépense et
se regroupement qui peut paraître une
bonne idée d'avoir les coller les
commentaires et l'école maternelle au
même endroit on a dans bavier à cause de
sa configuration une énorme difficulté
de circulation et Monsieur kuberley pour
sa propose de construire une nouvelle
route qui va aussi coûter beaucoup
d'argent on a chiffré ça mais vous me
démentirez peut-être autour d'un million
de nouveau et surtout qui va empiéter
sur une zone naturelle sur une zone
humide les pousser encore plus loin les
les limites de l'urbanisation alors je
vous dis si un expert nous dit ça coûte
trop cher de rénover ça
ça n'est pas possible alors nous
envisagerons peut-être cette solution
mais dans un cadre global d'écologie de
solidarité et démocratie de démocratie
participative
Eric coberley vous êtes un écologiste de
la dernière heure par heure opportunisme
a dit votre concurrent de gauche
monsieur lorida vous n'avez pas ce
Lorena vous n'avez pas le monopole de
l'écologie les femmes et les hommes qui
m'entourent sont tout aussi écologistes
que vous bavier et nous l'avons prouvé
dans notre premier mandat c'est une
ville à la campagne et nous voulons
renforcer ce statut nous avons fait
durant 6 ans une priorité du cadre de
vie nous allons intégrer l'école dans un
cadre naturel et nous allons donner à
nos enfants un cadre de vie et un cadre
d'apprentissage idéal et d'ailleurs nous
allons construire une école verte une
école durable et nous allons revaloriser
ce secteur naturel en lui donnant une
véritable plus-value environnementale
Charles
toujours pas convaincu les propos
n'engage que Monsieur Burley je suis
inquiet quant à l'endettement de la
commune puisque les aides de l'état du
département du Grand Belfort ne sont pas
acquis une école c'est un minima 5
millions pour une école classique je
dirais Erico berlès que vous vous
engagez si vous êtes réélu et que vous
construisez cette école puisqu'il y a
des doutes sur le financement à ne pas
augmenter les impôts locaux pour la
financer
premier mandat nous nous sommes engagés
sur un programme nous l'avons réalisé en
intégralité sans augmenter les taux
d'impôts et en diminuant la dette de la
commune en 2020 la dette de la commune
est inférieure à ce qu'elle était
lorsque j'ai pris les reines de la
commune avec mon équipe en 2014 très
bien ça c'est le bilan mais vous n'avez
pas répondu à ma question sur les impôts
futurs est-ce que vous engagez ici à ne
pas les augmenter pour financer
notamment cette école les impôts ont été
stables pendant tout mon premier mandat
ils seront stables pendant tout mon
deuxième mandat
allez-y je me permets d'être un petit
peu dubitatif puisque pour financer
certains projets vous avez vendu une
part du patrimoine de la ville vous avez
reçu un
héritage vous avez pas vous la ville
vous avez vendu une partie du domaine de
la ville ce qui vous a permis de
réaliser certaines choses que l'on ne
conteste pas sans augmenter les impôts
tout à fait est-ce que vous allez
pouvoir continuer à vendre des petits
morceaux de Bavilliers j'ai quelques
doutes
en tout cas nous l'avons montré pendant
6 ans
Eric cobarlet vous parliez tout à
l'heure de l'offre de soins
Gérald lorida parlait de du combat pour
le maintien du bureau de poste le bureau
de poste à fermer c'est lié que
voulez-vous faire dans les locaux de
l'ancienne poste d'abord le bureau de
poste n'a pas fermé la poste aujourd'hui
est confrontée à une baisse d'activité
et donc il y a eu une mutualisation
entre le bureau de poste et le bureau de
tabac aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
constate la plupart des bureaux de poste
ont fermé pendant le confinement or à
Bavilliers notre bureau de poste est
resté ouvert et les bavirons bénéficié
de ce service certes au bureau de tabac
mais ils ont bénéficié du service postal
durant tout le confinement au bureau de
poste maintenant dans les anciens locaux
de du bureau de poste nous nous
proposons puisque nous sortons d'une
crise sanitaire importante et que les
bavilleroyes se rendent compte que la
santé est quand même une donnée
essentielle ils ont besoin de médecins
dans la commune et donc nous allons
créer dans les anciens locaux de La
Poste un cabinet médical avec quatre
médecins
l'orida que dites-vous de cette
proposition je dirais d'abord que je ne
bosse pas mon programme
en contre de Monsieur kuberley non mais
vous avez une contre-proposition sur ces
locaux de l'ancienne poste pour mettre
monsieur kuberley côté si ça arrivait ce
serait une conséquence de notre
programme or à cet endroit là nous avons
d'autres projets
d'un côté nous avons d'autres projets
qui est de faire de ce lieu un pôle
socio-culturel de la ville on a la
mairie la médiathèque une salle de
spectacle une salle des associations
qu'il faudrait sans doute faire bouger
pour installer ce cabinet médical et
donc nous avons un projet autour de
cette place qui a été goudronnée il y a
pas très longtemps elle est toute noire
alors qu'on parle du problème des points
chauds urbains dans les villes cette
place nous allons la reverdir et
installer un pôle
socio-culturel entre la médiathèque et
la maison voilà d'autre part mais il y a
pas de salles de lieu pour
le type d'activité à baviller
aujourd'hui alors il y en a un autre
puisque il y a le parc de la fraternité
qui a été construit avec une une belle
structure à laquelle il faudra donner
vie
en organisant aussi des choses en
faisant vivre notre projet c'est faire
vivre ma vie un point sur le cabinet
médical de l'autre côté de la rue il y a
un cabinet médical et à deux kilomètres
à Belfort va s'ouvrir un des plus grands
cabinets médical de France je suis pas
sûr qu'il y a un besoin prégnant d'un
nouveau cabinet on va poser la question
Eric coberley il y a des besoins de
cabinet médicaux supplémentaires sur le
secteur bavier nous avons 5000 habitants
sur ces 5000 habitants il y a 400
personnes âgées monsieur lorida vous
parlez d'un cabinet médical important
qui va ouvrir à Belfort je ne suis pas
sûr que les 400 personnes âgées de
Bavilliers est vraiment envie d'aller se
faire soigner à Belfort si elles peuvent
avoir des médecins en proximité c'est
d'autant mieux je précise pour ceux qui
ne connaîtraient pas la géographie
précise du Territoire de Belfort bavier
touche Belfort c'est une commune
limitrophe bavier touche Belfort mais
vous savez certaines personnes âgées ne
conduisent plus ou en tout cas si elles
peuvent éviter de conduire et éviter
d'aller dans une grosse structure
médicale belfortaine elle préfère
peut-être rester se soigner en proximité
tant que c'est d'autant mieux les
médecins qui aujourd'hui travaillent à
Bavilliers ils sont débordés ou ils
peuvent encore accueillir des patients
il y a un besoin de médecins
supplémentaire absolument non non les
trois médecins de bavier Roy sont
totalement saturés et ils ne prennent
plus de nouveaux patients et donc là
nous aurons quatre médecins dans ce
cabinet médical qui vont pouvoir prendre
des nouveaux patients alors de manière
plus générale on constate dans le
Territoire de Belfort dans l'ensemble du
Nord Franche-Comté des difficultés du
tissu économique il y a de général
électrique encore il y a quelques
semaines à Belfort il y a évidemment
tout l'industrie automobile qui est en
difficulté aujourd'hui comment une citer
comment une ville comme la vôtre peut
résister continuer à attirer des
habitants et leur facilité de la vie
dans ce contexte économique social
Gérald lorida je vais vous demander de
faire des réponses rapides parce que
vous êtes un peu en avance sur le temps
de parole s'il vous plaît d'accord alors
rapidement c'est
proposer un accueil et un conseil aux
personnes qui sont qui sont chômage et
notamment au chômage de longue durée
avec un projet qu'on est en train de
regarder qui s'appelle territoire zéro
chômeur de longue durée
Eric Cobert les mêmes questions
l'attractivité d'une commune elle passe
par les services j'ai parlé d'un projet
d'école important je parlais d'un projet
de cabinet médical l'attractivité d'une
ville elle passe aussi par le dynamisme
de ses commerces il y a beaucoup de
commerces à baviller ils sont nombreux
aujourd'hui mais ils sont pour certains
en difficulté et il faut les soutenir
après cette crise nous avons pris
récemment deux mesures pour soutenir les
commerces d'abord supprimer la taxe
locale sur la publicité extérieure pour
cette année ensuite supprimer les droits
de terrasse pour les commerces qui ont
des qui ont des terrasses et puis nous
avons créé dans le premier mandat une
association de commerçants que nous
allons soutenir davantage encore dans le
deuxième mandat c'est clé la première
mesure pour attirer des habitants c'est
le dynamisme commercial selon où
uniquement il y a le dymanisme
commercial mais il y a aussi le
dynamisme de la vie associative bavier à
une vie associative qui est aujourd'hui
riche dynamique la mairie investit plus
de 40000 euros par an pour le
fonctionnement des instituts des
associations et la mairie finance aussi
des investissements nous avons créé un
terrain de foot synthétique pour le club
de foot et les jeunes de la commune 400
jeunes qui l'utilisent aujourd'hui nous
avons rénové le terrain de boules et sur
le prochain mandat nous souhaitons
investir dans un dojo pour permettre à
l'association du foyer communal de
pratiquer les arts martiaux dans la
commune
sur la vie associative vous aussi vous
faites le même constat c'est dynamique
tout va bien il y a j'ai envie de dire
ah bah vieille il y a tout pour faire
d'une belle ville pour en faire une
belle ville attention que certaines
choses ne disparaissent pas il y a
quelques années
l'alcool de musique a disparu
le dojo a disparu
étonnamment monsieur kuberley vous nous
reparler du dojo une semaine avant ou 15
jours avant l'élection je pense que on
aurait pu et d'ailleurs on aurait pu le
nez ensemble peut-être mener un combat
trouver des nouveaux locaux pour cette
école de musique pour se pour ce dojo et
effectivement je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est ce centre de ville autour
des associations de la médiathèque de la
salle de spectacle nous c'est comme ça
qu'on veut rendre du dynamisme à cette
ville et donc si elle est dynamique si
les gens vivent à cet endroit là ils
iront dans les commerces à la
boulangerie
au bureau de tabac librairie etc
Erico berlé le dojo vous le sortez de
votre chapeau au dernier moment
effectivement
je me suis engagé en 2014 sur un
programme la création d'un dojoint n'en
faisait pas partie mais j'ai réalisé
l'ensemble du programme avec mon équipe
sur lequel nous nous sommes engagés nous
engageons aujourd'hui sur la création
d'adojo si nous sommes réélus quand nous
serons réélus nous réaliserons ce dojo
pour l'école de musique monsieur lorida
ou tricher un petit peu l'école de
musique n'est pas une compétence
municipale c'est une compétence
communautaire et vous le savez donc la
mairie n'a rien à voir avec le transfert
de l'école de musique entre bavier et
Belfort sauf si elle fournit des locaux
l'école de musique de bavier a été
transférée au phare à Belfort c'est à
deux kilomètres et demi d'autant plus il
faut quand même signaler que tous les
jeunes bavier roi qui pratiquent la
musique n'allaient pas forcément à
l'école de musique de Bavilliers puisque
la répartition entre les différents
sites de l'école de musique ne se fait
pas par proximité géographique elle se
fait par pratique instrumentale donc
c'est un faux débat allez on arrive au
terme de ce premier débat émission
spéciale élection municipales sur France
3 Franche-Comté
Eric coberley c'est à VOUS d'entamer la
conclusion pouvez-vous conclure je vous
donne une quarantaine de secondes oui le
28 juin bavierroise bavier Roy vous
choisirez un maire vous choisirez aussi
une équipe et vous choisirez un
programme en tant que mère j'ai tenu mes
engagements je dis ce que je fais et je
fais ce que je dis
les hommes et les femmes qui m'entourent
sont représentatifs de la ville de tous
les quartiers toutes les générations
toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles sont représentées
nous sommes les seuls à avoir un
programme clair un programme précis nous
voulons investir pour l'avenir de
Bavilliers dans le domaine de
l'éducation de la santé du cadre de vie
nous voulons renforcer la solidarité et
la citoyenneté et nous voulons soutenir
l'emploi local en donnant du travail à
nos entreprises nous ferons de bavier
une ville attractive et active une ville
citoyenne une mine solidaire c'est notre
responsabilité et c'est notre devoir
merci
Eric coberley Gérald de lorida votre
conclusion s'il vous plaît nous avons
construit un programme ensemble avec
toute une équipe et je suis le
porte-parole je suis le coordinateur de
cette équipe et je sais comme ça que je
conçois le rôle du maire nous
proposerons autour des points de
l'écologie de la solidarité et de la
démocratie participative c'est important
je me conformerai en toute transparence
en suivant la charte d'anticorps de
suivre
ces principes de transparence et nous
implanterons une vie au cœur de la ville
en revernissant la ville et donc le 28
juin je vous propose de tourner la page
pour qu'une autre ville soit possible
merci à tous les deux je vous souhaite
une bonne fin de campagne